Have you ever had to have a really tough
conversation with your parents?
Well, I remember one like yesterday.
I can still feel the knot in my stomach,
31 years later.
Just imagine me.
I was a fresh engineer
out of Michigan State University
with my first real job offer,
with guess what?
My dad's number one rival.
You have to understand,
I grew up in Flint, Michigan.
My dad was a GM guy all the way,
like his dad before him, his brother
and all of his friends.
They were GM lifers.
But thankfully, my dad
was satisfied with the fact
that at least I'd be working
for one of the "big three."
Now, when my granddad started
working in the auto industry
in the mid 1940s, it was booming.
Fun fact:
popular cars at that time
were the Chrysler
Town and Country Hardtop,
the Chevy Stylemaster
and the Ford Mercury woody station wagon.
It was the modern age of transportation.
Now, today, we're experiencing
another major transformation.
Many are calling it
the electric vehicle revolution.
Now with that comes unprecedented change
that will require us to build new capacity
and collaborate in ways
that we've never seen before.
Now the change begins
with sustainable products
that provide better experiences
and greater benefits
for the people that use them.
We will need to build new capacity
to meet the demand,
support infrastructure and build
a responsible supply chain.
All while collaborating in ways
that we'd never seen before
with new partners,
like working with Tesla to bring more
fast chargers to more consumers.
And now other manufacturers
are following suit.
Now, I sincerely hope
that people leading companies like ours
will work together,
collaborate and learn,
and help each other succeed.
Now our goal is to become
carbon-neutral no later than 2050,
and our carbon footprint
is as big as Australia's.
We know that we need to make
the transition to electric vehicles
and clean energy fast.
Now with that,
to transition and to make sure
that we can get to our long-term goals,
this is what needs to happen.
First, we must continue
to make awesome products.
That can't go away.
Share a couple of pictures with you.
This is my uncle Daniel,
this is my uncle Willy.
They both drove premium
foreign cars for decades.
You know, I began to work on them
right away to make the switch to Ford.
(Laughter)
So in 2011, I actually pitched to them
the Lincoln MKZ Hybrid.
This vehicle had the latest
safety technology,
it had an interior like a fighter jet,
it had a smooth ride, a distinctive look,
41 miles per gallon.
And it was built by an American company
in their home state of Michigan.
And it was the same price
as the gasoline version,
but way better for the environment.
They each bought one.
The lesson is --
(Applause)
We can't make the change
feel like a trade-off.
We are building on the strength
of our current products.
We are electrifying our most
iconic vehicles first,
like the Mustang and the F-150 truck.
(Applause)
Now tell me this is not a hot car.
(Laughter)
It's all electric,
instant torque,
0 to 60, in just 3.5 seconds.
(Cheers)
And look at that chic design.
(Laughter)
But my point is,
when we improve our vehicles
to be more sustainable,
we also have to make them better.
And there's no better feeling
than driving right past a gas station
on my way home.
(Laughter and applause)
Knowing that I can get
a full charge just overnight.
Now, my daughter and her friends
are always bringing
their cars home on empty.
Wouldn't be a problem
if they drove electric.
(Laughter)
Now let's look at the F-150 Lightning.
The F-150 Lightning can power
your house up to ten days.
Imagine the impact on rural communities
if they didn't need a generator
when the power went out.
People who drive electric vehicles
can also light and heat up a campsite.
They can charge up a work area,
supercharge a tailgate party --
(Laughter)
and even charge another electric vehicle.
Now these are product improvements
that my granddads
could never have imagined.
Now with that, with all these new
products coming to the market,
next comes capacity.
We have to build and invest
in new facilities and talent.
Now that's true for any industry
transitioning to greener goals
and strategies.
Now I'll tell you a few things
that Ford is doing.
But we're not alone in this area.
In Tennessee,
we are investing more
than five billion dollars
in electric vehicle
manufacturing for trucks
and advanced batteries.
In all of our facilities,
our goal, for either new or old,
is to conserve and reuse water,
use 100 percent carbon-free electricity
and send zero waste to landfill.
And we are also investing in talent,
we're investing in education and training,
and we're also listening
to the communities
where we live in an operate.
That's huge for industries like us.
We have to listen to people
other than ourselves.
Now I tell you,
in Tennessee, we've created
more than 6,000 new jobs.
And again, we're not doing this alone.
As an industry,
we have invested more
than 120 billion dollars
in electric vehicle manufacturing.
We’ve created 143,000
new jobs in the last eight years
and 40 percent of that,
40 percent of that happened
since the US government approved
the climate and clean energy legislation.
(Applause)
And again, we're not alone in this.
We continue to make progress,
but we're going to need to do more.
We need to build ...
more infrastructure here.
Infrastructure is critical.
We will need charging stations
as plentiful and convenient
as gas stations.
In the US, we have
about 145,000 gas stations
and only about 23,000
fast-charging stations.
In order to make the move
to electric vehicles fast,
we'll need many, many more.
Now, I'm not saying we're going
to need one on every corner,
but we will need many, many more.
We need every community,
whether rural or urban,
wealthy or low-income,
everyone will need access to charging.
And the charging station,
we must bring lighting, shelter,
security, restrooms, basic amenities.
These are things that we will
need to move forward.
And one hopeful move
is the new federal spending
that will allow states to deploy
fast-charging every 50 miles
along major highway corridors.
And the benefits are real.
Let's take a look
at the 110,000 electric vehicles
that Ford has put on the road since 2021.
These vehicles have the potential
to save five million tons
of carbon emissions
over their lifetime.
That's equivalent to CO2 saved
by not burning 600 million
gallons of gasoline.
Like my family before me,
I am proud to work alongside my teammates
in the automotive industry.
We have come a long way.
It's so gratifying to see
electric vehicles on the road.
To move from aspiration to reality.
To see plants dedicated
to building electric vehicles.
But outside of the US,
in Asia, where I lived
for three years, and Europe,
they're way ahead of us.
Here's what we need to do
to make sure that we're ready
for an all-electric future.
We need policy makers to harmonize
environmental regulations.
We need one framework
to drive a resilient grid faster.
We need to strengthen the supply base here
and still create more jobs here.
We have the technology,
we have the leadership,
we have the ingenuity to respond
to the environmental crisis with courage.
And I'll tell you,
entrepreneurs, venture
capitalists, manufacturers,
everyone is beginning to understand
and accept the social responsibility
to build a future
of electric vehicles here.
And they are also seeing
the business opportunity before them.
And I'll tell you, as a person
who's dedicated my entire
career to sustainability,
the road ahead is paved with promise.
And it might surprise my dad,
it's not going to be about Ford
versus GM or Stellantis
or even the US versus Asia or Europe.
We all have to work together
to build a better future
for the next three generations
of my family and yours.
Thank you.
(Applause)